a flat slightly sloped plane
running down to perpetually boiling sea
strong gusts of wind and unbearable
pressure
the sky is overcast with dense dark
clouds
and a huge but dim red sun pierced
through an opening between them at the
very horizon
a moment later the opening between the
clouds is overcast
the sun practically does not move from
its position but it will take a while
before it is seen again
this world appears lifeless and
forbidding
but in fact it isn't the case
cosmo the first in outer space
this is a kind of landscape one would
see in the least harsh part of a planet
dubbed by scientists as super earth and
the closest potential candidate suitable
for searching for alien life forms
but let's be consecutive
the recent past heralded a boom in
discovering exoplanets
there are 4 370 exoplanets discovered in
over 3 000
planetary systems so far in addition to
these
more than 3 000 objects are awaiting
confirmation of their exoplanet status
most of them are large bodies gas giants
super jupiters and super earths
this is accounted for by technical
features of the technologies used for
the purpose
it is easier to look for massive bodies
with a short orbital period than to try
to spot
smaller planets similar to the earth or
mars in terms of dimensions
there are among exoplanets those that
may realistically harbor life
there are dozens of these objects
scattered in space
and they understandably draw scientists
close attention
today we're going to look at one of
these objects which is an exoplanet
dubbed gliese 832c
in fact this exoplanet is one of the
most likely places where
alien life forms will eventually be
detected
this exoplanet orbits a star called
glieser
832 which lies 16 light years away from
the sun
and is part of the gru's constellation
gliese 832 is a dim red dwarf
whose luminosity is just 0.7 percent of
that of the sun
both its mass and diameter are
approximately two times smaller than
those of the sun
and its temperature reaches about 3300
degrees
kelvin that is the reason why the
habitable zone of this planet is within
quite
a short range from its star due to tidal
forces the planets lying in the
habitable zone of gliese 832 will be
tidally locked to their star
that is will face the star with one side
only just as it is the case with the
moon and the earth
and mercury and the sun there are two
confirmed planets orbiting gliese 832
the jupiter-like planet glieser-832b
was discovered first astronomers
announced the event in 2008.
with the mass two-thirds out of jupiter
the planet orbits parents start a
distance of an average 3.4 astronomical
units
completing a full orbit every 9.4 earth
years
the discovery of the other confirmed
planet gliese 832c
was announced in 2015 by an
international team of scientists headed
by robert wittenmeier
it got an exceptionally high rating for
its similarity to the earth
0.81 to be more exact which instantly
attracted both scientists
and reporters it was also nicknamed the
second earth
even though the two planets parameters
are rather different
either way this is one of the planets
closest to the earth with such a high
earth similarity index the mass of
glieser 832c
is five and a half that of the earth it
takes the planet
35 earth days to complete a full orbit
around its parent star
moving at a distance of an average 0.16
astronomical units
this is six times less than the distance
between our earth
and the sun its orbit's eccentricity is
rather high
with the planet regularly leaving the
habitable zone and then re-entering it
this must cause sharp temperature leaps
and drops on its surface
gliese 832c is estimated to receive
approximately as much energy flux from
its parent star as does the earth from
the sun
the average surface temperature on the
planet is 253 degrees kelvin or 20
degrees celsius below zero
it is also suggested that due to the
atmosphere which is likely to be quite
dense
the temperature on the planet may be
considerably higher
however it is not easy to claim this
with certainty as gliese
832c lies quite close to its star
and so chances are it is firmly tidally
locked to it
in this case there should be a
substantial temperature difference
between its sunny side and shadow side
which should regularly cause hurricane
winds if the atmosphere really is
dense it's worth mentioning that in 2017
following observations astrophysicists
from the university of texas
at arlington the usa put forward the
hypothesis that there may be a third
planet in the glieser 832 system
its mass could be 1 to 15 earth masses
and it could follow a stable orbit
around the center of the system
0.25 to 2 astronomical units away from
it
at the moment the planet is being
searched for
let's imagine what gliese 832c would
look like
assuming life were possible on this
planet
first of all we wouldn't help noticing
its gravity
which would be strikingly higher than
that on our earth
since the planet's diameter is not yet
known the gravity force cannot be
calculated exactly
still it would be a rocky planet similar
to our earth and death-like
planets in terms of its density so its
gravity force would be likely to reach
two to four hundred percent that of the
earth this would lead to the relief
leveling out
meaning that the mountains would not be
so high and the oceans not so deep
this in its turn would enhance the area
of warm water which is favorable for
life
due to a dense atmosphere and a
comparatively dim sun
the landscape on gliese 832c would be of
a reddish hue
and in general the planet would be
submerged in semi-darkness
since the planet is likely to face its
star with the same side at all times
the temperature on the sunny side should
be high and the temperature on the
shadow side quite low
in the ring-like area at the border
between them the temperature should be
moderately comfortable
although due to regular heating of the
planet the atmosphere would be
constantly in turmoil
which should result in strong winds in
addition
high objects of relief potentially able
to dissipate some of the force of
hurricane air currents
fail to form on account of high gravity
conditions
as the orbit of glieser 832c is small
and elongated
seasons on this planet should change
every week it will be winter on gliese
832c at the furthest point from its
parent star
and summer at the closest approach the
tilt of the rotational axis with respect
to the ecliptic plane
will not be of such importance as it is
in the case of the earth
the change of season will depend
exclusively on the planets getting
closer to or away from its parent star
the most favorable conditions for life
to develop on gliese 832c
are likely to be in the ring-like area
at the border between the light and the
dark sides of the planet
it is here that most liquid water will
accumulate
and rain down from clouds formed on the
warm side
ice caps on the dark side will also melt
in the border zone
thus supplying still more water it goes
without saying that it is water that is
key to developing life
the change of seasons will be likely to
play the same role as lunatides on our
earth
with areas alternately submerging and
re-emerging
this process of water getting mixed with
substances dissolved in it
is a good prerequisite for life to
originate and develop
there is a good chance of life
originating in water and probably
staying in it without later spreading to
land
the ocean reduces the effect of gravity
and protects its potential inhabitants
from sharp temperature changes
and hurricane winds as for frequent and
sharp changes of seasons
hypothetical organisms on gliese 832c
may learn to lapse into a state of
anabiosis in order to weather unpleasant
although short periods of high and low
temperatures
alternatively they may choose to
emigrate to a comfortable temperature
zone from the sunny side
to the shadow side and back again for
example
if a space probe ever reaches the
surface of gliese 832c
to investigate the area what would it
see there
assuming life did originate on this
planet as the gravity forces are rather
strong there
the potential inhabitant should be a
thick set chunky figure
boasting a robust skeleton and powerful
muscles
plants on gliese 832c would be dark
in order to attract as much light as
possible
they should also be quite low and likely
to be creeping or moss-like
with strong roots able to stand winds it
is highly likely that rather than
chlorophyll
some other molecules should be important
for photosynthesis
the planet's dense atmosphere may become
a habitat for bizarre life forms
floating in air currents
single-celled microorganisms for
instance may float in this dense
atmosphere following air currents
while capturing light and nutrients
dispersed in the air
because of a dense atmosphere high
clouds and a dim sun
the surface of gliese 832c would be a
rather dark
place life forms would have to adapt to
these conditions
the vision would probably not play the
decisive role in their existence
if it evolved at all alternatively its
spectrum may be limited to the infrared
range
be it as it may all these speculations
remain conjectures and ideas
even though they're based on good
physical laws and assumptions
i wonder which of these suggestions you
would call realistic
and which of them bordering on fantasy
or perhaps
gliese 832c is not habitable at all
let us know in the comments and let's
keep in touch
you